So last week we talked about morality and the fact that morality points to God gives us some evidence for the fact that a divine
Creator actually exists. Now for these next couple of units you might be thinking well, why are we talking about beauty
agency and story?
Now these next few lessons are not as
difficult as what we've tackled in the last few last couple of months
But don't gloss over these don't just kind of fly through them like they're no big deal because they seem kind of strange
These are also
Incredibly important
pointers to God and these are gonna help lay a foundation so the students can see that
God is present in their everyday lives and things that they just see and interact with on a daily basis
So for this week, I want you to sort of take a step back and I want to do some
Evaluation and I want you to kind of look at some of your students and take a minute and really try to figure out where some of them are
Ask yourself a number of questions
Do a little bit of evaluation to figure out how you're gonna best move forward into this next sort of half of
Of your year of your year
So the first thing I want you to really do is spend some time thinking about where your students are
Where are they?
And I don't mean, you know, they're in youth group or they're not in youth group
But where are they?
right, if you if it's a very beginning you paid attention to
Where they came in and what they were actually thinking about and the questions that they had think about, you know
Some of the questions that they had
Some of the thoughts or beliefs that they had
Those are all important to figure out where they are now
Now you may have maybe noted a few students specifically
I would go back and look at some of those notes and see have there has there been any change
Good or bad, right? Do they have new questions with the questions that they had have those been have those been answered?
Secondly, do you have any new students?
Now that you've been going for a while, it's kind of easy
To get into the rhythm and forget when new students arrive
This would be a great time to ask yourself
Do you have some of our essentials materials on hand see if I were you I would always have
Five or six of our essentials books on hand ready to go anytime a new student walks out of the door
To make sure that they can be brought up to speed pretty quickly and that they don't feel super
Intimidated when they're walking the door about we're in the middle of this crazy big study that you guys are working on
And if you have new students coming in
What are the questions that they have right are they?
Students who are seeking are the skeptics
Are they you know your our traditional church students that just find a church did they move what's going on?
Have some sort of you know even a matrix to understand where your students are coming from so that as you move forward
You can track this same question for these new students
Are there reoccurring questions? Are there still?
questions and
My mean by this is are there the same questions
Are you not answering questions? Do we have the answers yet?
It's something to consider or are the students just constantly bringing up the same question
I don't mean questions about stuff
You're going to get to because you're going to get to it
But questions about anything that's within the curriculum so far are there reoccurring questions
You might want to think about what you need to do to take some time and maybe pause
Actually
Answer these specific questions head on find the answers and and get to them
So the students can kind of move on in their minds because a lot of times the students if they get hung up on a question
They have a hard time moving through to the next thing. They need those things answered oftentimes
Especially some of your brighter students who just are like super inquisitive and want to know things if they have a question
They have to have that answered often
So you know what you're gonna want to stop and get those questions answered
Which students are tracking?
now this is sort of
so that we often
forget about is
Some of our students track really well
And it might be easy for you to get hung up on those students that do
Because those are the students as you're talking to your group or the people in your small group
They are either you're talking a lot raising their hand or the students are like super engaged and like really really paying attention to you
It's easy to get focused on those students. It's good to notice it
But don't get overly focused on it because what you're what you're gonna end up doing is you're gonna forget that there are students still
That are pushing back
Are there students?
Pushing back on you is there a student. I don't mean verbally. I mean the kid in the back that's doing this
That has that look on their face like
I'm not buying it. I'm just not buying it
I would engage that student not in front of everybody
But after it's all done after you know before after whatever when there's a little more
One-on-one time is asked that student like hey
I noticed you seem kind of questioning do you have a question about what what I was saying
Don't be afraid to engage that student a little bit. Those are some of the most fun students
But I'm gonna put a caveat because there's probably a couple of different camps depending on where you sit
Okay, some of you are gonna get focused here
Because you want that like affirmation that like hey everyone's listening to me and this is great
And I've got these students tracking to be honest. That's sort of my my push is I love the students that that really really get engaged
And ask great questions and in those kind of things some of you might get like totally, you know
Dialed into what these students are doing and you forget everybody else
However, some of you might get really dialed in to these students like that's my project
I want I want to get that student
I want to do everything I can to make sure that student before they walk out of here believes in Jesus
I'm gonna get that student to you know to accept Jesus and I'm gonna
Great goal, but don't do that and forget about everybody else. It's easy to get you know switched on to one or the other
There's everybody else in the middle to you don't want to forget them either. Okay, but ask yourself where your students are
So you get a pretty good idea
I'll never forget one particular student that I had
Years ago one of my apologetics class. He sat in the back for probably the entire class
Arms folded feet up on the desk looking at me like this is the dumbest class ever
Why am I here? I have to be here. I can't switch out of this class and I'm stuck
I remember every time I just would basically give my lecture or my talk or the discussion
Whatever we were doing for that day. I would like focus it right on him
To make sure that I was talking to him and I would look for little hints
Little just changes in the eyebrow or changes in posture and nonverbals just to see what he was thinking
And then every day after class as the students were walking out
I would ask so how was class today to me further questions. What's going on?
How are you? I'd seen the class or in the hallway at different point in the day
And I would ask questions to sort of even say anything just to get nonverbals out of him to see if I was making progress
By the end. I never saw him except Christ, but by the end he said there's something to what you're saying
It's all I ever got. I honestly don't know whatever happened after that
I just pray that somewhere along the line. He has found Jesus
But at that moment that was awesome because I knew I was moving him in the right direction
Okay, so that's a whole lot of observations a whole lot of stuff that you need to think through
So now you need to figure out. How do you move forward?
How do you go to the next level? How do you do the next sort of things that we have coming?
Now it might just be keep going just keep on the next thing keep on doing the next thing and it's no big deal
But it might be do you put the brakes on someplace?
Do you go back to an old lesson and revisit something?
Think through and don't be afraid to make some adjustments if that's what you need to do
Because remember there's gonna be ebbs and flows. There's gonna be ups and downs
But the goal is to provide our students with what they need to be prepared
To move the gospel forward and to proclaim the kingdom. That's the goal